um what I want to talk about today is
just a story of tools it's it's my story
in finding the right tool to use and
funny enough the speaker before is my
friend Paul who works at lucidchart and
that's where I learned to write
javascript was at lucidchart in the
summer of 2013 and so when when I
started this internship I had never
written any JavaScript and we had a huge
JavaScript code base hundreds of
thousands of lines and it was kind of
intimidating to get into as a beginner
with just a couple years of programming
experience and one of the biggest
reasons it was intimidating is because
of the tools we were using to edit our
code so I came from at BYU where I did
my undergrad we would use Visual Studio
and Eclipse to write C++ C sharp Java
and these tools had lots of integration
right like as a freshman programmer
it's like okay I typed this and then I
press f5 and everything just magically
works well when I when I moved to this
more JavaScript environment we had all
these all these make files and we had
all these different things we had to run
from the terminal in hindsight it
actually was great for me and my
learning to be a good programmer because
I learned how a lot of these tools
worked but there was quite the learning
curve I had to had to learn even the
code navigation I remember a lot of my
fellow developers were just masters at
global find and they'd know some reg X
to find where this method was or where
this objects defined so as missing some
of that as I was moving around and even
like people were using vim and Emacs and
I remember the first time I got stuck in
in vim I didn't know how to get out of
it it what was it : escape I just
couldn't like it you maybe you remember
your first time in vim 2 but I just shut
down the terminal I had to start over
whatever I was working on eventually I
found sublime text which was which was
awesome how many of you use sublime
today yeah it's a really popular tool
and it was really great for me it
finally it got me into just at least a
shallow learning curve tool that was the
idea didn't have my integrations right
that I had
in the bigger ide but it was simple I
didn't have to remember keybindings to
start and stop the editor and and it had
some really nice things like the plugins
what one of my friends said oh here if
you copy and paste this Python script
you can now get all these packages which
was cool so I could install plugins into
sublime and really kind of cater it to
my type of experience but there was some
things I was missing especially in
school you I got used to this where I
could just set a breakpoint I hit the
breakpoint I could step through this and
and I always wondered why I had I
couldn't have that in in in sublime text
and it maybe there were some packages
ways ways around it but how I did it at
lucidchart at least was and later when I
was working at my startup if I needed a
debug something I would fire up IntelliJ
go to the bathroom get a drink because
it would take a while for it to load I'd
come back and then click through all
these gooeys because I never could
remember exactly where it was finally
find it look up how to configure
debugging and there we go needless to
say if I had to pull out the debugger it
was a pretty big bug most of the time I
just stuck to my console dot logging and
that was good enough for me um so this
this kind of led me where I'm going with
this is I'm making a checklist of the
features that matter to me for my editor
and then I'm gonna show you where Visual
Studio code or vs code fits into that so
the things that were important what at
which I loved with sublime was it was
fast it was simple it was very
customizable we could have different
themes one of my difference just had a
beautiful-looking
development environment all the time and
I like that I like that experience in
sublime extendable which I talked about
and easy good support for multiple
languages like when I was using Eclipse
it was great for Java but if I needed to
write a Python script or bash script I'd
have to go to a totally different tool I
liked that in sublime I could at least
get syntax highlighting in colorization
that was great support for multiple
languages but there's two features that
I really missed in my sublime experience
and in the code editor is this idea of
intellisense which is kind of a my
your safety word but it essentially is
meaning this a context-aware
auto-completion so and you can get some
packages and sublime that'll do that for
you but this is like if you've used
Visual Studio if you've used the clips
you know this is your API documentation
right at your fingertips and in further
code navigation you could command click
into methods it made it easier to reason
about the structure of the code and then
the last one here on my checklist is the
debugging which I talked about before um
so so what is Visual Studio code like
I've tried to show here or word I'm
gonna show here's Visual Studio code is
not Visual Studio so it's meant to be a
lighter way editor and there's there's a
three key differences with Visual Studio
first via SCOTUS cross-platform some of
you may wonder why did Microsoft build
this editor well you were the reason
Microsoft built this editor and what
we're trying to do is we we recognize
there's a whole bunch of developers on
Mac and Linux and and even some
developers on Windows that we don't
reach Microsoft doesn't reach well it
doesn't give them good tooling and we
just don't know them very well and what
what their future needs could be so the
big mission for vyas code is to build
something and go where those developers
are and I like that like when I joined
Microsoft I said as long as I can use a
Mac I'm happy to go so it's
cross-platform it's it's very fast it's
been a the key feature from the
beginning I I blocked out the comparison
here just because I don't want to bash
on our on alternatives to vs code but
but this is the community sediment is vs
code is fast and we have a lot of
engineering resources that go into
keeping it high performance and then
finally it's free and open source and
you might be wondering wait isn't this
the Microsoft that Bill Gates started it
is the Microsoft that Bill Gates started
and we actually have a lot of good open
source initiatives at Microsoft but vyas
code is one of the flagship open-source
products at at Microsoft and we have a
lot of transparency and our planning we
put all our iterations on there and it's
a fun product to work on because of that
so we're we try to land here's we've got
the IDE s on the far side and then the
editors
and we try to land somewhere in the
middle favoring the editor side so you
can see we're clearly influenced by a
demand sublime in our design and and how
things look but we tried to cherry-pick
the features that we we felt like we're
missing from the editor experience
intellisense and debugging so let me
show you I'm gonna go through this
checklist and show you how vs code fits
each of these characteristics or styles
that I was looking for in an editor
especially as I was starting my journey
with JavaScript we're gonna first go
here to code and we're gonna download
the product so if you've ever downloaded
Visual Studio you'll notice the
difference here
it's about 47 Meg's so pretty small we
can download it in just a few seconds
and unpack the zip and start the app yes
open so pretty small and and fast to get
going yet that's we're trying to be
sublime like in that way and then very
simple there's only a few buttons here
on the on the left hand side we have a
status bar here on the bottom that gives
you information about the files and then
you have your familiar command palette
where you can find any if you want to
find the settings anything you want to
find command wise is in the command
palette and then our quick open which I
don't have let me open a folder here
oops
I'm not getting this right Wow open
Tejas conference so if we want to
quickly go to our different files we can
do that too and we can do some neat
things like entering this at symbol we
can do some symbol navigation makes
pretty simple so does is vs code fast is
it simple I'm giving it a check and a
check so customizable we we can do
change our theme here kind of a nice
thing you can easily
review it what its gonna look like if
you really want to go sublime like you
can go with Monica here stick with the
default and then a recent addition we
added is this file icon theming so
notice the files on the far what's that
your guys is left changing next to the
files so you can do that if you want to
find more of those in the marketplace
you can can install those I've installed
a lot of them that are available
changing keyboard shortcuts is easy a
number of you that I've talked to you Oh
too small thank you for telling me that
it looks big to me so so changing key
bindings is easy and and this is a style
we've taken with a lot of our stuff is
we want to bring you right down to the
code so you'll notice changing keyboard
shortcuts is editing a JSON like file
and the purpose of this is we want to
make it easy to check things into
version control or to share it across
teams kind of bring you closer to to the
code that you're used to here with
settings if we go in here you'll notice
we actually get this intellisense
experience so I just do a simple control
space and this gives me if I want to
turn off the line numbers so I can type
in line numbers I can see how to do that
right there that makes it easier and and
we feel more comfortable to developers
in their style and what we like is
developers so that settings and key
bindings check that off for customizable
with the themes and the file icons now
the extensions we have a number of
extensions now this one this first view
here shows me the different ones I have
installed now this was a pain I had with
sublime at times was just knowing which
extensions I had installed and what what
they were actually doing for me so we
tried to we tried to solve that in a few
different ways so this this allows me I
can look at this get history one for
example which that's strange you reload
that see if
fix's and you can see all the
information on how the extension is
supposed to work right here in the the
details view see the different
contribution points and there's some
pretty cool extensions that people have
built for example this chrome debugger
which this is also small sorry about
that there's some issue going on with my
lazy man you can hook up chrome to be
the debugger envyus code and you can do
that via an extension essentially what
it's doing is allowing you to set the
breakpoint in vs Co to not have to
context switch to Chrome which is pretty
nice and in a whole bunch of others so
here's our show popular extensions you
can see this is where we give our
multiple language support so you're
gonna get syntax colorization for other
languages out-of-the-box and then for
javascript and typescript those are our
first-class languages that we ship with
and the idea there is that we're
providing intellisense code formatting
refactorings all those language service
like features out-of-the-box and if you
want it for other languages you can
install an extension that does that it
keeps the tool lightweight but then
allows you to customize it so you can
see c-sharp python we have a really good
go extension and then there's a lot if
you want to look for linters you can
install es Lin J's hint a bunch of
different things to make this extensible
and personalized to what you're looking
for in your editor I'm so extendable and
support for multiple languages so let me
show you now I wrote this code whoops
and I just closed it there we go you got
last May I wrote this little app how
many of you guys watch the the big game
on Saturday this is the Utah BYU game
okay I watched the game even though it
was tough to watch but I I wanted to
build the follow up here just just to
see if BYU could ever beat Utah let me
load this well
loads I'll show you a little bit about
the code so I have this front-end app
and it's I have two two processes
running here one is the web pack dev
server is going to be serving up my my
front-end and then I have this back-end
service that's just giving me a
demonstration purpose to show the front
and the back end differences so going
back here so this armwrestling match
so what we're gonna do see if BYU can
beat Utah at armwrestling Utah wins
again okay what maybe maybe they'll win
just just one more time it's a kid okay
maybe maybe it will just be why he's
destined never to beat you two okay so I
want what I want to do in the app is I
want to build just something to keep
track of the records so we can see over
time who has the most arm wrestling wins
so I have some of that plump plumbed up
here but I want to add a little bit more
as I show up until a sense and we'll
zoom into the code so we'll look here
first at this handle click is that big
enough for you guys out there in the
peanut gallery okay and we get some good
things here so if I do this dot this is
your like Visual Studio Eclipse like
experience you can see we're giving you
what we can intelligently figure out is
are the methods on this object which is
great and then if it's provided we'll
also pull in the documentation any sort
of parameters and they're in there types
you can see here that we're not
providing the type winner any there so
if we do this and then we say date a
winner we can see the parameter hints so
this is nice especially when getting
into a new code base or parts of the
code you're not familiar with it's
really helpful so we get that for the
our own code that we write through a few
different ways we get that with if you
are using typescript obviously we can
read the typescript type information we
also get that just running a type
inference algorithm
the code and doing the best that we can
to figure it out and then third we'll
get that through the jeaious Doc's if
you provide jaya stocks then we can give
you the type hints we also give that for
third-party modules that you'll install
so here's low - and this is pretty great
because this is a pretty large library
but if I so if I just type each for each
I can look here see the documentation
make sure it's the right method for me
hit tab and now I can see inside here
what I'm looking at what type of
parameters I want to pass in so this
state schools what I'm just refactoring
this for loop above to use for each
because that seems like a good style to
go for and we'll do this and then
there's a good same type of keyboard
shortcuts or hints you're going to see
and your other editors so that was the
alt down arrow to be able to do that so
we get first party third party and then
this gets pretty cool especially if
you're using react JSX we also give
intellisense for this and in a few
different ways so I talked about the
code navigation if I click here and I
say go to definition this is going to
bring me I look that's a problem Thank
You linter I can go in here and do peak
definition so I get this cool little
peak window this is nice to not have to
switch files all the time but I can just
quickly see if this is the type of file
I'm looking at and if I want to I can
make a quick edit so this is where I'm
going to do class name equals row I'm
just adding the the view on top of this
and notice how I also get intellisense
for the attributes of the JSX
which is pretty cool so like when I am
getting as I switch around different
products I always forget about this that
the that JSX doesn't use class but class
names so that's a nice little hint I get
and we're going to do calm it 12 close
that tag
then we want to show due style just
giving a little styling to our wins
record okay there we go we did all that
in the peek window and if we want to
jump into the actual context we can do
that as well so it makes it easier to
navigate around the codebase and
especially as I said with a new code or
code you're not as familiar with we find
that helpful okay
can we beat Utah this time now yeah and
every time
okay so intellisense and i'm setting you
guys up a little bit because now I'm
gonna show you that there's a bug in the
code causing Utah to win every time
so what we're gonna do now is show
debugging um and I'm got five minutes
left perfect timing so we're gonna go to
server J s looks like I left this from
practice we can set a breakpoint here at
our at our endpoint and then setting up
debugging is simple we you can go here
click this wrench and it will create
this JSON file so again this is like
it's nice you can check it into version
control shared across the team so
everyone has a familiar thing here and
then there's a few different ways to
debug so you can either have the
debugger actually launch the process for
you or we're going to you or attach or
attach the process I'm going to use this
attach process because I think it's
pretty cool remember my processes are
already running and I am now going to
it's going to ask me which of these
processes in the workspace do you want
to connect to I'll connect to server J s
and now I'm going to hit arm-wrestle
yeah not not exactly sure why it stopped
there but maybe I left a stray
breakpoint so now now we're here we're
in the debugging view you can see if I
click here I'm back to the file
browser debugging view it gives me the
locals over here and then I can click
through the call stack that's on your
guys's far left and see where the where
the code has been and then I can also as
I'd expect and this is what I am trying
to drive home was I was missing this
when I was learning how to write
JavaScript and as I was looking for
tools to help me is I can easily hover
over here and see the nature of my data
as it's getting passed in and then I can
step through my code or step into it
just like we'd expect and here's the bug
go you it's X square equals BYU return
Utah that's a problem
let's get just for demo sake let me show
you another cool thing here I can
actually get hit in here and see the get
blame looks like this was done by Utah
rocks so try it
trying to mess things up for me so we'll
go in here and delete this and then we
can just detach the debugger I actually
need to just restart that real quick
there we'll load another one well well
that's loading let me show you a couple
other cool things we I've been using
this task command which so if you've
used webstorm phpstorm they have this
task runner so we we brought that in on
the lightweight way essentially it's
this small file tasks JSON and it allows
you to hook up to your two vs code
different commands for running whatever
you want to run so this can be go up NPM
here I'm having it execute a batch
script and essentially gives this like
f5 type experience like I just press f5
I can detach a key binding to this and
get it so let's see now who's gonna win
Utah wins it's got to happen one time
BYU wins there we go okay
and so to close it off we can then
commit this code right here you can see
I get a nice dip view I can write a
commit made life fair again and and the
command if I needed to undo it I can do
that I can rebec rebase and pull and do
a whole bunch of other things so that
wraps up debugging I showed you a couple
others integrated terminal we didn't go
over but that's another cool feature
thank you for your time I'd love to
connect with you I'll be around tonight
and we're on twitter at code and at Wade
Ryan underscores mind